der amerikanische supreme court der
oberste gerichtshof in amerika hat
vergangenen freitag ein historisches
abtreibungs urteil wieder für nichtig
erklärt und damit die debatte um das
lebensrecht von ungeborenen kindern in
amerika wieder auf werkseinstellung
zurückgestellt und man muss sagen das
ist auch gut so und bevor jetzt alle
feministin schnappatmung bekommen und
alle denken das mittelalter sei zurück
nein der oberste gerichtshof hat nicht
das recht auf abtreibung abgeschafft er
hat allerdings die kompetenz wieder
zurückgegeben zu den einzelnen
bundesstaaten der usa das heißt was
jetzt passieren wird ist dass jeder
einzelne staat endlich das recht
bekommen die abtreibungs gesetzgebung so
zu regeln wie die leute in diesem
bundesstaat es für richtig halten das
heißt es wird wahrscheinlich
fristenregelung beratungsregelung und so
weiter geben wie wir es auch in
deutschland haben das gericht hat das
begründet damit dass sie sagen es gibt
kein universales menschenrecht auf
abtreibung und das ist ehrlich gesagt
überfällig denn man muss sehen in den
usa haben wir inzwischen zustände das in
einem bundesstaat new york selbst
lebensfähige vier kilo kinder noch bis
zum einsetzen der wehen mit einer
spritze getötet werden dürfen im
mutterleib weil man sagt es sind keine
kinder und mit verlaub eine gesellschaft
die so etwas erlaubt die ist nicht
modern und auch nicht emanzipiert
sondern suizidal frau keine das gesetz
was ich gelesen hatte gegen bis zu 28
woche und dann bis zur 24 woche das war
der stand amerikas generell vorher jetzt
ich habe mich gefragt als ich ihre these
vorab gelesen habe manche staaten hatten
ja wirklich schon das abtreibungsverbot
in der schublade die haben nur darauf
gewartet dass der supreme court ist
entscheidet was mich sehr schockiert hat
das möchte ich gerne einmal mit der
runde teil der staat im ist also in
missouri dürfen jetzt abtreibung gar
nicht mehr vorgenommen werden und was
mich wirklich schockiert hat ist nicht
meins bei vergewaltigung oder inzest
sondern nur wenn ein medizinischer grund
vorliegt und das ist ja die große angst
der feministin eigentlich generell das
jetzt tür und tor geöffnet wurde dafür
dass frauen gar nicht mehr abtreiben
dürfen in den einzelnen bundesstaaten
ich verstehe durchaus sozusagen diese
befürchtung gleichzeitig herzen
umgesehen
das stimmt auch dass diese gesetze auch
in der schublade waren wobei ich mir die
frage stellen was ist eigentlich falsch
daran was ist eigentlich falsch daran
dass ein bundesstaat für sich selbst
entscheidet man muss ja sehen das sind
ja länder von der größe die sind größer
als deutschland
das was hier es ist eine
grundsatzentscheidung die hier verändert
worden ist das nämlich dieser supreme
court gesagt hat wir sind gar nicht
zuständig es gibt kein verfassungsrecht
auf tötung eines ungeborenen menschen
und deswegen sind wir gar nicht
zuständig wir hätten nicht zuständig
sein dürften und mit verlaub wenn in
einem bundesstaat die mehrheit der
bürger eine regierung wählt die sagt wir
finden das richtig dass die bürger
finden dass auch richtig wir sind wir
dass wir darüber und heute jetzt gerade
nicht wählen die die die bürger das wird
jetzt umgesetzt weil er die
konservativen richter in den supreme
court gesetzt wurden die
republikanischen die frage die ich mir
stelle ist um noch einmal ihre ihre
meinung ganz konkret zu wissen finden
sie es denn richtig
was ihr zum beispiel misery umgesetzt
wurde das drei vergewaltigungen nicht
abgetrieben werden darf nur bei
medizinischen grund dass eine frau
beispielsweise sie haben eben überall
vier kilo kind kochen das ist legal in
new york und vier kilo und in china habe
ich selten auch derweil wurde in meinem
freundeskreis lebt aber was ich weiß
mich eigentlich interessiert ist die ist
die frage finden sie es denn richtig
dass beispielsweise seien in der
sechsten woche nicht abgetrieben werden
davor kein regen zogen vom gesetz nicht
vor gericht bei bestimmten vorfällen das
ist ja so wie es in deutschland geregelt
ich denke die regierung wie in
deutschland das gericht hat gründer
start ich mich gerne beantworten weil
die in der tat wie soll ich sagen wir
haben wir erleben ja dass diese debatte
immer genau an diesen extremfällen sich
ja tatsächlich ausgesetzt wurde ja wie
es auch in deutschland diskutieren in
deutschland ja nie der normalfall
irgendwie der abtreibung die einfach
stattfindet im übrigen häufig beim
dritten kind das wissen die meisten gar
nicht irgendwie also scheitern häufig
ist oder nicht sagen es ist gar nicht
die dass das junge 16-jährige mädchen
oder die vergewaltigte frau das heißt
diese sogenannte kriminologische
indikation wie das so schön heißt macht
in deutschland irgendwie 0,1 prozent der
fälle aus oder so das heißt wenn wir uns
darauf einigen können und in deutschland
hat man ja genau deswegen im übrigen ein
hart errungenen kompromiss gemacht dass
man sagt für diese extremfälle müssen
wie eine lösung haben weil keiner von
uns glaube ich auch hier auch ich nicht
einer frau vorschreiben will kind von
einem vergewaltiger auszutragen das sind
genau die grenzfälle das problem ist
doch etwas völlig anderes nämlich der
normalfall zudem es geworden ist dass
manche frauen das inzwischen quasi als
nachträgliche verhütung quasi benutzen
oder oder das überhaupt nicht mehr
drüber nachgedacht wird das ist doch das
und ich glaube das ist genau diese
zuspitzung der debatte die auch in einen
amerika stattfindet dass man einfach
sagt die sind in extreme abgedriftet sie
sie führen debatten wo sie sagen das ist
noch kein mensch ist es jetzt nicht das
andere extrem zu sein ist da gar nicht
mehr leben heraus ist das andere extrem
und das zeigt für mich zeigt das sehr
gut was in amerika passiert erstens mal
dass man sagen muss diese debatte kann
man nicht festhalten man muss
vernünftige lösungen finden und in
amerika hat man jetzt 50 jahre extrem in
eine richtung gearbeitet und jetzt ist
es genau wegen dieser extreme ist es
jetzt gekippt und dieses wieder
freigegeben und ich glaube es wird in
amerika jetzt harte debatten gegeben um
das in ein gleichgewicht zu bringen auch
mit fristenlösung vielleicht auch mit
beratung was ich für sehr sehr wichtig
halte weil ich kenne das selber ich
kenne selber diese situation dass man
ungewollt schwanger ist und völlig
ungeplant und dann ist es wichtig dass
man nachdenkt dass man kurz innehalten
kann dass man auch menschen um sich hat
die nicht alle nur sagen oh mein gott du
bist schwanger sondern vielleicht auch
irgend jemand findet der sagt oh toll du
bist schwanger denkt drüber nach willst
du bist du sicherlich 48 stunden darüber
nach in deutschland haben sie drei tage
in deutschland haben sie drei tage und
sie haben die beratungspflicht und ich
halte diese beratungspflicht für
wirklich wichtig nicht um frauen zu
gängeln sondern um ihnen eine atempause
zu geben und um ihnen im prinzip zeit zu
gewinnen diese teilweise nicht haben die
sie auch nicht haben auch das ich kenne
viele beraterin die am telefon beraten
junge frauen über die hälfte sagen sie
werden eigentlich von ihrem partner
getrennt
der partner sagt ich will das kind nicht
so ja das ist keine selbstbestimmte
entscheidung mehr für eine frau ja eine
frau die im stich gelassen wird ja die
alte das gefühl hat alleine dazu steht
eigentlich müssten alle feministin auf
der straße sein und gegen diese männer
kämpfen um diesen frauen weil diese
frauen treiben oft nicht abweisen weil
sie sagen ich will kein kind haben
sondern weil sie sagen keiner steht zu
mir ja der mann lässt mich setzen
genau führt die diskussion
in den usa nicht dazu dass wir am ende
50 verschiedene regelungen haben das
jahre hinter das eine ende abtreibungs
tourismus entsteht dass jeder dann
entscheiden in new york geht das aber
nicht genau ist eigentlich kein problem
das ist ein richtiger kontinent wo ist
eigentlich das problem dass es
unterschiedliche regelungen gibt in
verschiedenen statt es haben jetzt schon
firmen entschieden also verschiedene
firmen haben ja schon gesagt sie würden
den mitarbeiterinnen die betroffenen
sind abtreibungs urlaub bezahlen also
dann können sie in anderen staat fliegen
oder wie peter mit dass derzeit so
reibungslos
dort haben sie das board kurz sie will
ermöglichen wenn sie es also ein
aggregator um sein und irgendwohin zu
reisen um sein kind umzubringen und dem
arbeitgeber bezahlt das ist nicht wie
perfide das ist das ist eigentlich
kapitalismus pur ja der arbeitgeber
bezahlt ja ab 3 daniela bals prozess
nicht unterbricht
anstatt dass der arbeitgeber sagt wir
helfen dir dein kind großzuziehen du
verlierst auch dein job nicht und er
zahlen dem mutterschaftsgeld das würde
ich als sozial empfinden aber ein
arbeitgeber der sagt ich bezahl die
raserei bahn oder auch gegen die
abtreibung beispielsweise der sechsten
woche ich bin da gea ist ja auch ein
extrem jahr innerhalb kilo als sie auch
ja aber das ist ja das schlimme sind das
schlimme ist endlich die grund
argumentation die dahinter stehen weil
die sagen ja die sagen ja das ist noch
kein mensch dass er das der hat noch
keine menschenrechte im innkreis saal
nebenan holt man aber frühchen mit 500
gramm und pc mit allen regeln der kunst
auf weil man sagt das ist doch unser
kind ja das heißt man muss sich doch als
gesellschaft einmal festlegen gewährt
sagt das ist ein kind dann darf man es
nicht einfach fragen den mal ein mann
hätte wenn ich mache jetzt was ich gar
nichts böses mit ihnen bei dem team ein
mann
woraus
aber jetzt zu sagen obwohl sie keine
frau sind kein kind bekommen können aber
ist ein potenzieller fährt man habe sie
nur die männer warum soll ich nage
wissen meine eher aufpassen wo sie also
noch dreifacher vater blut ich finde
dass man frauen generell
die entscheidung überlassen soll als bin
ich nicht ganz ihrer meinung ich finde
frauen soll man bis zur woche iks die
entscheidung selbst überlassen ohne wenn
und aber ob sie abtreiben wollen oder
nicht ist für mich einfach noch also wie
das deutsche modell eigener ist
wir fragen wir erfahren heute ich glaube
wir haben da so eine lange diskussion
gehabt dass wir uns alle daran
orientiert haben und damit war nicht
frieden der aber im augenblick scheint
es ja sozusagen dass er
die bewegung dahin geht dass wieder
auszudehnen und insofern muss man sagen
wir haben glaube ich mittlerweile den
guten kompromiss in deutschland gefunden
und bin dann werden sie auf amerika
blicken was haben sie da empfunden bei
der nachricht ist dort jetzt vom gericht
aus auf jeden fall nicht mehr legal ist
ja das ist glaube ich das ist
verfassungsjuristen rey da muss man
glaube ich wirklich sagen da gebe ich
frau keller recht der spruch der sagt
das ist jetzt kein es gibt kein
menschenrecht auf tötung des kindes das
hat steht nicht in der verfassung dass
muss jetzt jeder staat für sich
entscheiden müssen immer sehen das ist
ja amerika besteht eben von san
francisco bis new york aus ganz vielen
staaten und da hat jeder eine andere
tradition da gibt es also gewaltig ganz
anders als san francisco und da musste
jedes land das für sich empfinden aber
ich glaube es gibt ein paar dinge die
müsste man schon als korsett vorgeben
eines wer zum beispiel für mich die die
ungewollte schwangerschaft durch
verbrechen und ähnliches dass das würde
ich sagen das sollte man eigentlich für
so einen vereinigten staaten von amerika
generell respektieren scheint nicht der
fall zu sein viele feministinnen wie
frank ehrlich gesagt war auch wie ich
sagen würde normale frauen und männer
für die ist es auch einen aufschrei und
ich glaube ich stehe jetzt nicht im
verdacht eine woge feministin zu sein
die immer für alles ist aber ich kann
schon dieses signal von 1972 wieder
rückgängig zu machen und zu sagen jetzt
ist abtreibung nicht mehr legal das hat
mich so sehr gestört frau keine weil da
fand ich wurden wir frauen wirklich
wieder mit blick das gericht ist
eigentlich zurückgeworfen und zwar um
viele viele jahrzehnte und dass man muss
aber sehen das ja viele frauen auch
anders
also das ist ja auch nicht ein kampf für
mich frau gegen mann oder so sondern wir
sehen dass das sowohl unter männern als
auch unter frauen völlig
unterschiedliche positionen zu dem thema
gibt und dass man darüber einfach die
debatte wieder eröffnet hat also
theoretisch
wir sagen steht es jedem bundesstaat in
den usa jetzt zu tatsächlich wieder
alles zu legalisieren das ist ja
überhaupt kein thema es gibt eben es ist
freigestellt so das heißt es wird jetzt
die debatte eröffnet und und dann wird
es ein demokratischer prozess sein und
dann wird darüber abgestimmt werden
insofern sage ich die debatte ist offen
sie ist nicht sagen das gericht hatte
daraufhin die legal hat nur gesagt ihr
müsst jetzt alle frau kelly wir wissen
ja schon die einzelne vor allem
republikanische staaten in amerika jetzt
entscheiden werden also es ist jetzt nur
ein beispiel was ich heute mitgebracht
hat mit missouri aber wir können uns ja
sicher sein dass staaten folgen berg ja
das ist nicht die reha bahn deutsche mal
wenn die menschen die in diesem staat
leben eine das so für richtig empfinden
und deswegen so eine regierung wählen
wir sind wir denn dass wir ihnen das
vorschreiben dass sie es anders machen
sollen also mich wundert ein bisschen so
zu sagen warum wir uns gedanken machen
darüber weil weil gerade auch weil es ja
ein großes land ist und gerade weil man
auch nur über die grenze fahren muss um
es doch machen zu lassen wenn man es
will ja ist dass ich bin sicher dass
quasi dass das jetzt schon daran
gearbeitet wird das in wenn in
bundesstaaten ist nicht möglich ist dass
die frauen das kostenlos woanders
bekommen das wird alles passieren aber
ich halte es für legitim und ich halte
es auch für angebracht da soja
angesichts von wirklich millionen
abtreibungen
dass wir darüber nachdenken ist das
eigentlich richtig und wenn wir mit
derselben energie daran arbeiten würden
auch in deutschland da haben wir etwa
100.000 abtreibungen jedes jahr ja weil
immer noch frauen in deutschland glauben
sie könnten unter deutschen bedingungen
ihr kennt nicht bekommen ja wenn wir uns
mit derselben energie mit der wir dafür
sorgen dass sie ihr kind loswerden
können dafür sorgen würde dass sie ihr
kind kriegen können ja dann hätten wir
auch ein problem gelöst und das wäre ein
problem lösung für die frau das wäre für
mich echte frauenarbeit und echte frauen
politik dass wir den frauen ermöglichen
zu sagen ich sagte ja zu dein kind und
nicht wir bezahlen die die abtreibung
der schlussphase ihrer these gehört in
frage